>> Okay Michael, you go an answer for me? This isn't meant to be a hard quiz.
>> Oh good. Cause I actually have two answers for you.
>> Oh, I like that.
>> So I would say right, right, up, up, right.
>> Okay, so, right, right, up, up, right.
>> But I feel like I could have also said up, up, right, right, right.
>> And you could have. Both of those are acceptable. right, right
does what you think it does. You move right and then right and
then up and then up and then right. And
that takes five steps. Or you could have gone
up, up, right, right, right, which would also have
taken you five steps. So that's pretty easy, right?
>> Yeah, I thought so.
>> Rag. So yes, either of these would be correct. We're going to
stick with this one in particular, since they're equal, because we gotta pick
one of them. So this does point out something that often in
a decision problem like this, there are in fact multiple answers or multiple
optima, if I can tie it back
to our randomized optimization discussions. Okay, so you
got the quiz, you got the world, you understand what you can do here. Yes?
>> Yep.
>> Okay, cool. Now I'm going to throw in a little wrinkle.